pop
[Musique]
1ère
m
à
[Musique]
m
aïe
et bien amis de toutes les villes et
villages de france vous pénétrez en même
temps que nous sur les gradins du
fronton municipal de bayonne là où des
centaines qu'on ne pas dire des milliers
de bayonnais sont installés pour
défendre les couleurs de leur ville dans
une ambiance toute particulière toute
méridionale comme vous pouvez le voir
dans quelques secondes nous irons à dax
sur les gradins des arènes où d'autres
milliers de dacquois qui sont installés
pour représenter évidemment leur ville
et répondre aux baïonnettes en effet ce
soir les caméras d'intervilles 62 pour
vous faire vivre les péripéties d'un
derby à ces passionnés qui s'annonce
très mouvementée dax bayonne jeudi
dernier vous vous souvenez que vous avez
assisté à la rencontre
saint-amand-les-eaux armentières qui
s'est terminé par la victoire de
saint-amand saint-amand-les-eaux où on a
dansé toute la nuit à armentières on a
presque mis les drapeaux en berne
c'est vous dire combien les villes qui
participent à cette émission prennent à
coeur leur rôle et nous les en
remercions
nous remercions également d'ailleurs
tous et or qu'est ce qu'ils sont ce les
gradins et que qui couvrent peut-être un
son un peu le son de ma voix
remercions surtout ces deux villes du
nord d'avoir ouvert le feu pour notre
émission vainqueur comme vaincus nous
ont bien aidés dans une tâche difficile
et j'en profite également pour remercier
tous ceux et toutes celles qui nous ont
manifesté leur sympathie dans cette
kermesse dont semaine kermesse de
détente de bonne humeur
on ne se prend pas au sérieux dans
intervilles on s'amuse nous sommes un
peu en vacances et c'est d'ailleurs
pourquoi nous avons remplacé ce soir les
fauteuils des sempiternelles studio par
les gradins les gradins ce fronton et je
me trouve d'ailleurs parmi la foule
ayant à mes côtés à droite et à gauche
de ce petit clocher symbole de notre
émission les deux équipes culturel
représentatif des deux villes d'ailleurs
à ma droite d'abord celle de bayonne
représenté par son sympathique capitaine
monsieur cusack monsieur cusack non mais
on est déjà on accapare tout à bayonne
quel est votre profession mais suffisant
et professeur au lycée printemps
bon eh bien vous me présentez maintenant
et mettez pas 30 ans à le faire gros vos
deux coéquipiers voici monsieur jean
verdun c'est en verre d'un bonjour
et voilà monsieur jacques simonet vous
aimez vous pourriez quand même dire les
professions de ses deux assesseuses
bondé le plaisir rires monsieur jean
werder au nom prédestiné bon
directeur d'école en vacances oui ils
dorment et maintenant aussi monnet l'un
des avocats les plus distingués du port
de bayonne très bien et bien bonjour
messieurs c'est merci évidemment que des
hommes dans cette tribune met des
visages sympathique et d'ailleurs je
veux dire que toutes les beautés basques
sont parmi nous ce soir je passe de
l'autre côté du clocher pour faire
connaissance avec l'équipe de dax
bonjour monsieur verrai je crois
président du tribunal de dax vous allez
pouvoir siéger ce soir je crois en toute
équité et vous allez me présente et bien
sûr les deux autres équipiers de dax
j'ai pour un c serm noël courtial livré
rédac bonjour mademoiselle monsieur père
est professeur au lycée dax et un risque
homonyme je ne vous demanderai pas
quelles sont les chances de dax
je n'ai pas demandé quelles étaient les
chances de bayonne dax bayonne bayonne
dax
je crois qu'il ya dans la tribune
beaucoup de partisans de bayonne puisque
nous sommes à bayonne au point central
mais il y a quelques éléments
perturbateurs qui sont un glissé qu'est
ce que vous en pensez bayonne d'un grand
bain je pense que bayonne en principe
gagne toujours à toujours des victoires
et bayonne le sait nous sommes comme
pour nous tu as eh bien je vais laisser
ce colloque de ces deux supporters qui
peut être en viendront aux mains mais
enfin très amicalement au cours de cette
émission est maintenant nous allons nous
rendre à dax pour faire connaissance
avec les dacquois et la présentation des
équipes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
bush
[Musique]
mais quel manque élevé pour les courants
nets est prégnant
dans les lettres des laïcs
[Musique]
les vaches hésitant un petit peu a
attaqué les jeunes gens qui sont là mais
bon sang dans le temps les bayonnais les
excitants qui peut avec l'heure où la
teinte rouge
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
avec la pauvre vache ayant le numéro du
moins à l'être a appelé par les
bayonnais vous voyez donc que le fait
que les hommes aient chassé les vaches
pas du tout du moins je l'espère de
bayonne va prendre le pack dax c'est
tout simplement pour vous rappeler qu'il
s'agit d'un jeu dans la bonne humeur à
l'écurie tu mets du mouvement nous
l'espérons un jeu à la bonne franquette
c'est à dire de quoi s'amuser
de quoi rire de ville à ville est bien
en place pour le premier jeu comme vous
le dites leone pour s'amuser et pour
s'amuser au jeu du certificat d'études
monsieur verdun pour bayonne monsieur
paierait pour dax devra bel messieurs de
ce jeu en toute amitié veux que vous
alliez à repasser votre certificat
d'études se dire je ou poser dix
questions que vous avez d'ailleurs
peut-être suivi à quinten une vingtaine
enfin bon insistant pas et je dois vous
dire que c'est un jeu de vitesse vous
avez un petit interrupteur dans la main
appuyée tous les deux dessus pour voir
quel est le premier voyez vous avez
allumé vous monsieur verdun le premier
donc un petit signal lumineux s'est
allumé un petit signal sonore a dû
retentir si notre technique avait marché
elle va marcher ne niez n'ayant
absolument pas peur dans quelques
instants
dix questions vous êtes reposé le
premier d'entre vous évidemment qui
répond à 15 secondes pour répond aussi
répond une marque un point s'il répond
pas nous en retirons est déclaré
vainqueur celui qui à l'issue des dix
questions aura évidemment totalisé le
plus de poids il fera à ce moment-là
marqué un point sa ville vous êtes prêts
tout cela vous paraît clair le moral est
bon dax bayonne c'est parti première
question de quelle ville
à quelle ville circula en france le
premier train pour voyageurs je dis bien
qu'on voyageurs à vos bayonne bayonne a
pris l'antenne c'est le cas de le dire
nous vous écoutons quelle est la réponse
paris saint germain
oui monsieur à quoi
[Applaudissements]
quand je me disais qu'il y avait de
l'ambiance plus de 10 millions sont en
train de battre je ne sais pas ce qui se
passe à dax nous verrons tout à leur
deuxième question quelle était la
capitale de la gaule romaine me suis
appuyé cedac ci prend la parole je vous
écoute
non monsieur vous marquez un poids de
moins c'est dire monsieur que vous allez
avoir à dire de bonnes réponses pour
vous retrouver à 0 bon eh bien ça marche
mal panda cnaf a rien n'est perdu
troisième question sur combien d'années
c'est en réalité la guerre de cent ans
dax a pris la parole il a répondu en
même temps que la sonnerie donc je pense
que pour tous les téléspectateurs il est
souhaitable que vous n'oubliez votre
réponse 115 ans non monsieur 125 - 2
pour dax
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quatrième question sous louis xiv
comment appeler ton l'impôt sur les
boissons
là il y en a pris la parole 15 secondes
pour répondent les aides
oui monsieur
[Applaudissements]
et je dois dire que vous aider
considérablement les couleurs de votre
ville en répondant les aides
vous êtes à deux points je signale
actuellement pour la bonne compréhension
de ce jeu que les deux points de bayonne
sont plus de que les deux points de dax
sont moins de quatre points séparent les
deux candidats cinquième question quel
est le nom donné à la première chambre
des députés de la restauration
bayonne la chambre des pairs non
monsieur je suis désolé je suis désolé
d'ailleurs je dois vous dire que le
titre était finalement va justifier
votre réponse c'était la chambre des
introuvables
vous n'êtes plus qu'à un point sixième
question c'est est introuvable bout en
bout kamel certificat d'études vous
allez c'est pas si facile qu'on veut
bien le penser
et bien justement petit artifical études
vous allez voir que cette sixième
question de circonstances quelle fut la
loi qui oblige est en 1833 toutes les
communes à avoir une école
dax encore bayonne bayonne la loi guizot
mais oui monsieur la loi disons qu'ils
me donnent deux fois et qui nous permet
de passer la 7e question comment
s'appelait c'est une très vieille mode
je m'en excuse pour les dames qui sont
ici comment s'appelait les pantalons
portés par les gaulois a évidemment on
voit plus ça que dax la femme a laissé à
écouter je ne sais pas si c'est une
prononciation dacquoise
mais ce n'est pas tout à fait ce que
j'ai moi voulait voir répéter lui chez
vous êtes très près de la vérité
malheureusement je ne peux pas vous de
cette réponse pour bonne parce que le
nom est très connue s'élèverait ne les
lèveraient - troyes - troyes pour
d'atomes et coûteux c'est pas grave il
s'est laissé la première épreuve elle ne
compte que pour 1 point
8e question par qui fut fondé la
sorbonne à des écoles nous sommes passés
à la sorbonne qu'un second
donc on hamm est répartie
nos deux écoliers ont passé l'âge sont
en train de chercher
comment dites vous appuyez sorbon c'est
exact vous n'êtes plus qu'à moins de la
dax 9e question et avant dernière et je
crois que c'est à vous de vous couvrir
de gloire dates des trois glorieuses
bayonne a pris le micro 27 28 29 juillet
oui monsieur
et grâce à cela vous en êtes à trois
points à -2 enfin dixième et dernière
question je pense que maintenant
bayonne ne peut plus être battu c'est
que pour l'honneur de ces trois villes
quelle est la ville la plus au nord rens
mais ce poste vous réfléchissez bayonne
a pris la parole mais eh bien non
monsieur serra je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
ça n'a pas d'importance par quatre
points d'écart bayonne bas taxes dans
cette première épreuve et marque le
premier point
[Applaudissements]
et nous avons
nous allons inviter le spectateur il
avait une façon de marcher les soins
respectent ils ont le très sincèrement
la dernière fois l'autre marqueur
n'avait pas très très bien marché c'est
pourquoi nous avons fait appel
un chanteur marqueur qui va nous
annoncer dans son bon accent de vasques
les points nous vous écoutons marqueur 1
points pour bayonne 1 point pour zéro
pour dax nous vous écoutons beauté au
lac inférieur
ces recours dac et
avait avec nous voilà une manière très
folklorique d'annoncer ces points nous
allons entendre ces points marqués et
annoncé de cette manière pendant toute
l'émission et notamment le point
maintenant de la deuxième épreuve car la
deuxième épreuve fond tu pourras points
et nous permet de nous rendre aux arènes
de dax
abou léon qui dit sud-ouest pense rugby
devant vous une mêlée à droite
le pack de bayonne qui pousse contre les
huit avants du pack de dax
si c'était une vraie partie rugby en
introduirait le ballon dans la mêlée
mais ce soir l'arbitré monsieur lafitte
va siffler et écarter la mêlée messieurs
bravo ils prennent place pour un nouveau
match bayonne dax toute l'histoire du
rugby français résonne depuis 50 ans des
chocs emprunt taxe et l'aviron bayonnais
mais ce soir il va s'agir d'une
compétition différente une ex discipline
olympique le tir à la corde qu'on
pratique à aux jeux olympiques d'athènes
en 1896 je vais vous présenter
de droite à gauche très rapidement les
concurrents pour l'aviron bayonnais
d'abord
la règle internationale 84 kg sublet 80
crespo 85
dharmendra y 98 et guy 98 la langue 93
arrighi 99 avoué et rooney
internationale le talonneur 75 et puis
au delà de l'adour l'adour personnes
comme des gens présentés ici par un
bassin rempli d'eau pour dax est
toujours de droite à gauche
béraud 80 kg berry les 98 bachelet 90
labadie 92 d'argos 90 l'international du
bois 94 laraque de 83 et l'international
qu'à syed 99 kg hab an dîner et 103 kg
en ce moment si j'ai bien aimé
la règle du jeu je vous le rappelle est
extrêmement simple il s'agit pour vous
de pratiquer le tir à la corde vous
tirer tout à l'heure dans un instant au
coup de sifflet de l'arbitré
il n'y a pas de mails et fax ou prends
pas de drogue pas d'essai l'équipe
gagnante sera celle qui mettra quatre
hommes de l'équipe adverse dans le
bassin monsieur l'habitude c'est le juge
1 2 3
avantage à bayonne
il y en a
a dakhla
ben non
elle a conservé
le faire simple
pepy
[Applaudissements]
davantage
dax reprend davantage
et le premier bailleur
[Applaudissements]
jeu de mettre un pied dans l'eau
regardez les
la goutte qui savent outre la partie
droite du bassin
à l'équipe de taxi déséquilibré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya toujours un homme de dax avec les
pieds dans l'eau deux gammes de dax
l'arbitré sifflé l'arbitré siffle et qui
avait deux hommes de dax les pieds dans
l'eau et tous les autres étaient tombés
le seul arbitre nous sommes bien
d'accord monsieur arbitre c'est un point
pour bayonne 1 points pour bayonne à
vous dit luc
[Applaudissements]
eh bien eh bien bravo bravo bayonne donc
va yonne à l'issue de cette deuxième
épreuve chanteur marqueur nous vous
écoutons
[Musique]
pour bayonne 0 contre 1
et je crois qu'ici la foule ne se sent
plus days eh bien nous allons j'ai
simplement oublié de vous dire que notre
ami léon zitrone avait oublié de
signaler son poids parmi les les 16
avant mais moi par contre je vais avoir
le plaisir grâce au jeu des familles
n'anticipons pas de vous donner deux
poids léger en effet nous allons passer
maintenant au troisième jeu qui vaut lui
un point ce troisième jeu va nous
permettre de retrouver deux familles
l'une de dax d'autres bayonne qui vont
avoir à identifier le prix de deux
objets deux objets seulement je le
précise si à l'issue des deux objets et
bien les deux familles sont à égalité
nous aurons recours à un troisième pour
les départager
je précise que dans ces objets si par
exemple je demandais le prix de ce
soumah et qu'il vaille 100 francs et
bien évidemment c'est la famille qui est
le plus près de 100 francs qui marque de
la manche mais les prix accepter ces 20%
tu 20% en dessous c'est à dire au delà
de 120 est en dessous de 85 serait pas
bon c'est vrai pour tous les prix que
nous demandons est maintenant eh bien
nous allons faire très rapidement
connaissance avec les deux familles tout
d'abord avec la famille de bagel abou
simone monsieur mathieu est un homme
heureux
vous le voyez ici devant une petite
maison typiquement basque avec dans le
jardin toute sa famille réunie et
également dans le décor de vache
paisible quoi que nous soyons ici au
pays des corridas mais je me tourne je
crois que peut-être vous n'avez recevez
pas très bien les 2 vaches paisible tant
pis pour monsieur mathieu combien
avez-vous d'enfants six filles qui
s'appelle comment bernard pascal alliés
philly jambières et dans l'ombre à la
petite jeune vient voilà mademoiselle
geneviève forte attendue efforts
souhaités avec ces cinq garçons c'est la
petite princesse de la famille que
faites-vous comme profession monsieur je
suis agent commercial qui fait les
achats dans la maison le plus souvent
matin eh bien écoutez je crois que
puisqu'il s'agit de madame c'est elle
que nous irons consulter pour ce jeu
avoue dax
merci beaucoup simone garnier à dax nous
avons autour de nous dans les arènes la
famille gillet monsieur gilles est quel
est votre profession j'ai rejoint
danthez vous jurer néanmoins de dire la
vérité toute la vérité
je le jure madame gilles s il vous plaît
de combien de personnes se compose votre
famille cinq enfants
où sont-ils man 2 ici et trois qui sont
allés regarder la télévision ailleurs je
les voeux de la famille par conséquent
nous avons ici simone garnier monsieur
et madame gillet deux de leurs cinq
enfants un de leurs neveux une de leurs
nièces
ils sont 6 contre vous contre la famille
de bayonne à bout bayonne
c'est très simple j'ai beaucoup de joie
bras de présenter christiane à ma droite
quel poids 51 kg eliane à ma gauche 54
kg voyez c'est beaucoup plus léger les
on essaie beaucoup plus gracieux
beaucoup moins peur aussi pourquoi la
présence de ces deux jeunes basques très
radicale bayonnaise d'ailleurs un
chandail enfin il est vrai que côté de
biarritz et bien tout simplement parce
que ces deux jeunes filles portent et là
je sors mon petit carnet parce que c'est
très important
il ne faut pas que je me trompe dans la
description porte sur elle deux
ravissantes robes en popeline d'alsace
vous allez avoir famille de dax et
bayonne a donné le prix le plus apprécié
en approchant de ses robes qui sont
d'ailleurs totalement identique
et je précise que la famille qui va
identifier le prix sera entièrement
habillés hommes femmes et enfants
gratuitement par le syndicat des
cotonniers d'alsace ce cadeau ce don
étant offerts par des villes
compétitrice de notre émission sélestat
et anne que nous remercions très
sincèrement au passage alors le prix
d'une de ses robes par les deux bien sûr
ils sont là toutes les deux mais il
s'agit que d'identifier le prix d'une
robe pour une minute en précisant que
vous n'avez le droit qu'à des enchères
de 10 secondes
attention de commençons par les enchères
de bayonne à bout simone elle est en
madame mathieu vous avez entendu vous
avez vu cette ravissante robe coupe
chemisiers en popeline d'alsace un prix
qu'il voulait
9000 francs alors neuf mille anciens
francs avoue dax je vous demande pardon
guy lux excusez-moi d'interrompre le jeu
mais madame gillet ici déclare qu'elle
n'a pas très bien entendu votre
description je vous demande s'il vous
plaît de prendre les 20 secondes
nécessaires pour expliquer à nouveau et
je vous en remercie bien il n'y a pas
grand chose a expliqué léo simplement
que ce sont des robes en popeline
d'alsace véritable qui sont portées
d'une manière extrêmement charmante et
je crois que votre maîtresse de famille
doit pouvoir identifier quel est le prix
d'une robe en popeline l'alsace alors
voulez vous commencez les enchères léon
s'il vous plaît merci beaucoup guy lux
madame vous avez entendu cette fois ci
lequel d'entre vous donnera le prix 80
nouveaux francs 80 nouveaux freins av ou
simone
alors madame matthieu 10 secondes un
nouveau prix vous savez que vous ne vous
occupez pas du prix de la famille
adverse mais que vous surenchéri sur
votre propre prix si vous l'estimez
douze mille francs alors douze mille
anciens francs a volé en madame et
monsieur je vous rappelle que vous ne
pouvez changer que par rapport à votre
prix vous ne vous occupez pas du prix
d'année à bayonne sans nouveau prend à
bout simone même mathieu qu'est ce que
vous faites est ce que vous vous
maintenez je maintiens 2000 francs vous
maintenez douze mille francs alors nous
maintenant où simone y sida ce monsieur
et madame il vous reste une dernière
répondront et leon
une seule réponse soit un seul enchères
le chronomètre je demande pardon 135
nouveaux francs 135 nouveaux fronts à
dax 12 nouveaux fronts à bayonne
et bien voici le prix réel 130 nouveaux
francs
des banques dakhil extremis qui marque
la première manche de ce jeu des
familles et qui est bien parti pour
marquer le point de cette troisième
épreuve
nous allons passer maintenant merci
bestial merci et liam
vous pouvez donner vos robes tout à leur
nom vous les gars dre nous donneront les
robes à la famille qui je le rappelle
sera habillé entièrement gratuitement en
popeline d'alsace et nous passons
maintenant au deuxième objet ce deuxième
objet est un objet très très particulier
puisqu'il s'agit d'un animal regardez
plutôt dans les arènes en effet pour
l'instant il ya beaucoup dans l'animal
n'est pas très visible pour l'instant
j'espère qu'il va se montrer puisqu'il
s'agit d'un jeune taureau
et je vais vous en donner la description
ce taureau a comme fiche signalétique un
an et demi il a été élevé au biberon par
conséquent on m'a dit qu'ils étaient
très gentils que c'était un taureau
familiale race espagnole vite qu'au bal
et d'un origines manade de monsieur
philippe poirier de beaulieu 3 200 kg
pour une minute enchères de 10 secondes
attention dax bayonne quel est le prix
de ce jeune taureau qui vous sera donnée
vous en selle propriétaire pour la
famille qui veut voir le prix le plus
approchant
alors madame monsieur 180 milles 180
mille ans donne toujours les prix en
anciens francs 280000 là-bas à bayonne
monsieur et madame gillet 1000 nouveaux
prend 1000 nouveaux francs c'est à dire
100 mille anciens à vous si bas alors
madame monsieur vous consultez votre
mari c'est très bien alors vous
maintenez mots qu'un malade maintient
toujours 190 enfants
béchir
15 cents nouveaux france va dire 156
abouti l'homme alors est-ce que vous
surenchérit c'est maintenant madame
mathieu vous avez encore dix secondes
attention
à tarière 195 195
vous avez dit 195 mm à 95 ici on
maintient le prix c'est à dire vous vous
rappelez dans un sens nouveau 15 100
euros francs et on ne s'en dédit plus à
vis ici mais bien c'était in extremis eh
bien je crois que les deux familles est
extrêmement loin du véritable prix qui
est de 500 nouveaux froid car c'est un
jeune taureau d'un an et demi je les dis
élevé au biberon mais ça ne jouait pas
mais ça ne vaut pas les sommes annoncées
par conséquent le taureau restera
monsieur poirier n'appartiendra pas à
aucune des familles et communient dax ni
bayonne n'ont marqué dans cette deuxième
manche
dax reste donc victorieuse de ce jeu des
familles et dax marque le poids de cette
troisième épreuve donc à l'issue à
l'issue de cette troisième épreuve
chanteur
c'est un big en coupe 1 pour 2 1 pour
bayonne
et maintenant bien nous allons passer à
cette quatrième épreuve qui est un peu
un tournant de notre épreuve si je puis
dire de notre compétition je ne sais pas
actuellement quels sont les visages des
dacquois les visages des bayonnais
probablement nous allons pouvoir les
voir sur nos écrans et ça doit
évidemment remuer du côté des supporters
dacquois qui sentent qu'ils peuvent
remonter et je vais maintenant vous
présenter les deux couples de mime
puisque vous savez que jeudi dernier
nous avons présenté pour la première
fois un jeu à moitié musicale à moitié
mi mai qui a d'ailleurs eu un certain
succès je dois dire grâce à une chanson
qui s'appelle les catcheurs et voici
d'ailleurs par conséquent ces deux
couples de mime alors rapproché vous je
crois que c'est le papa et la jeune
fille quel est votre nom monsieur
bernard hisquin madmoizelle com ans et
vous représentez la ville de bayonne
je passe devant excusez moi et
maintenant je présente les deux mimes
qui vont défendre les couleurs de dax
monsieur sportive jaune dix ans oui oui
mais oui d'accord
comment dites-vous laborde christine bon
je lui dis qu'il est sportif oui il
présentait des sportifs et des trésors
d'être beau gars aussi et vous
mademoiselle geneviève esgourdes et
alors vous connaissez bien la chanson ça
marche très bien vous connaissez notre
jeu je vous l'expliqué en deux mots je
reste au milieu de vous comme ça je vais
compléter le tableau de famille vous
avez avoir à choisir entre cinq
enveloppes une première fois des
chansons assez facile à mimer ses
chansons si vous les faites reconnaît
travaux orchestre et à vos municipalités
respectives
eh bien vous ferez marqué un point à
votre ville c'est donc très important qu
après vous tirerez dans une deuxième
série d' enveloppe et là les chansons
sont un petit peu plus difficile
si bien que si vous les faites connaître
encore à vos orchestre et a vomi sipa
lité et bien vous ferez marqué deux
points c'est dire que cette épreuve peut
rapporter trois points à une ville c'est
donc très important
s'il vous plaît mademoiselle nous allons
faire choisir je vais vous demander
simplement vous équipe visiteuse de
tirer la première
c'est toujours un honneur aux visiteurs
dans cette région nous sommes pour les
convenances et bien mademoiselle a tout
simplement pris l' enveloppe numéro un
jeu louvre jeudi à pour la technique
voilà le titre vous n'avez absolument
pas le droit de le prononcer bien sûr
bien sûr sous peine d'élimination et
maintenant attention pour 30 secondes
nous vous regardons j'ai la très nette
impression que ce titre n'évoque pas
chez vous un 6/6 ier a très bien j'avais
un peu peur quand le maître
colloque secret
n'allez pas trop loin et pas trop loin
notre podium ne fait pas de 100 m
actuellement il vous reste quelques
secondes pour en finir avec ce même
assez curieux et bien les 30 secondes
sont écoulés je serais curieux léon de
savoir avec votre orchestre et votre
municipalité si vous avez pu identifier
cette première chanson mi mai pour 30
secondes vous avez le temps de réflexion
avant d'interpréter cette chance eh bien
merci guy lux ici monsieur martin
adjoint au maire entouré d'un conseil
tout à fait charmant et féminin monsieur
martin vous savez de quel tweet si je
voulais vous en la gentillesse de lviv
mon beau chapeau mon beau chapeau dit on
à dax eh bien je ne sais pas en tout les
cas j'aimerais bien savoir si
l'orchestré capable d'interpréter
montrez vous de jouer messieurs
et bien ce top la musique nous avons
retenu mon beau chapeau gamme saks
messieurs maintenant nous allons avoir
vérification de votre réponse grâce à la
technique
écoutons si c'est mon beau chapeau ou
tout à fait autre chose je fais du bien
acheté dans l'histoire qu'ils se portent
place et bien droit sur le front il est
en général vers avec un petit noeud dans
le dos mais ça n'est pas du tout mon
beau chapeau c'est le chapeau de prosper
vous n'avez pas su trouver vous vous
écartez quelques secondes et maintenant
nous allons faire choisir la chanson
numéro 1 en fin de la première série à
bayonne le chiffre 3 le chiffre 3 vous
lisez le titre vous avez vu vous avez
réfléchi
nous pouvons y aller chronomètre pour 30
secondes
terminé merci pour cette sensationnelle
démonstration je ne sais pas si elle va
être suivi d'effets attention à bayonne
est-ce que vous avez deviné avoue simone
alors à bayonne ici parmi les jeunes
filles en fleur la municipalité les
musiciens alors ça y est on a un titre
mais la pluie ne cesse de tomber à mais
la pluie ne cesse de tomber
irma me vient plus près mais n'y vient
plus alors vous connaissez l'air alors
redonner un petit peu l'air pour les
musiciens parce qu'ils sont un peu
perdus en ce moment alors allez-y s'il
vous plaît allez la chorale la chorale
de bayonne
[Musique]
et
c'est bien sauf la musique mais
honnêtement merci je n'ai pas très bien
connu ce qu'a joué bayonne mais si la
technique envoie un disque en tout point
semblable je suis prêt à accorder le
point attention musique
il pleuvait fort sur la grande route
elle chemine ai l impression que le bât
grâce à ce volet s'est montré et je
serais tenté d'applaudir les deux mimes
mais pas l' orchestre
enfin pour l'instant niedax ni bayonne
nous marquer deux points
nous passons à la deuxième série des
chansons s'il vous plaît vous vous
écartez vous choisissez et tâchez d'être
plus brillant qu'à la première vous
savez que le score du match est entre
vos mains celles ci non non je vous
entends pas seulement par le numéro 6 le
numéro 6 à vous pousser des soupirs vous
avez peur c'est pas facile ça si c'est
très facile
alors attention si vous n'y arrivez pas
alors là vraiment bon pour 30 secondes
chrono m
eh bien eh bien nous allons interrompre
c'est extraordinaire démonstration qui
est fait avec beaucoup de grâce
je sais pas je ne sais pas mon cher léon
ce que vous en pensez et ce qu'en
pensent ceux qui vous entourent nous
allons le savoir eh bien merci guy
monsieur le maire
la chasse au papillon messieurs de l'
orchestre je vous en prie
la musique
merci d'avoir si vite interprété parce
qu'au fond ils ne doivent pas se
connaître du tout ses musiciens c'est
visible alors attention pour la
technique nous écoutons petit viable à
la fleur de l'âge l'argent belley dollis
et là là je croyais que je crois que dax
marque deux points très précieux et nous
allons immédiatement avant de faire les
comptes de cette quatrième épreuve
assiste au mime de bayonne le deuxième
choisissez vie d'une enveloppe voit la
jeune numéro 8
le numéro 8 vous lisez hausse est très
simple aussi nous allons passer un bon
moment attention pour 30 secondes chrono
m
heureusement que c'est le papa et la
fille c'est parce qu'ils se disent dans
le tour d'oreille
on
eh bien le chronomètre s'est arrêté sur
cette partie effréné simone est ce que
vous avez une idée surtout est ce que
ceux qui vous entourent et qui est oui
alors tout le monde en ce moment est en
train de réfléchir mais les musiciens
ont déjà trouvé la chanson ça y est la
partie de belote une petite belote c'est
ça vous êtes tous d'accord
alors messieurs les musiciens s'il vous
plaît
[Musique]
or la physique la musique et bien merci
merci à cet orchestre de bayonne
vérification maintenant musique
technique votre dada et bien j'ai
l'impression que ce derby promet qu'ils
avaient volé exactement donne ce que
nous avait promis car le score est
extrêmement serré jugez plutôt chanteur
nous vous écoutons
[Musique]
4 pour bayonne ou 3 et bien
[Applaudissements]
attention 4 à 3 c'est dire que tout est
encore en question est peut-être
peut-être la grande épreuve qui se
prépare maintenant dans les arènes de
dax vont nous permettre d'avoir une idée
du vainqueur de ce soir attention à
mauléon et bien une nouvelle épreuve
maintenant une nouvelle épreuve
typiquement régional les vaches
landaises vous allez voir à l'oeuvre les
écarteurs les sauter et les ravisseurs
de cocardes c'est un spectacle amusant
mais c'est un spectacle technique aussi
et cette technique va être jugé ici aux
arènes de dax par un jury de trois
membres que je vais avoir l'honneur
mesdames et messieurs de vous présenter
c'est monsieur joseph l'audois négociant
à ce test vous monsieur roger maïs
industriels à donzac
et vous monsieur se ranger du brusc et
même de pin il s'agit d'un jury de trois
personnes
présidée par le monsieur qui a parlé en
dernier et voici maintenant l'entrée
dans les arènes
on fait des conneries liens de bayonne
et de date
l'équipe de dax en béret celle de
bayonne tenu tête trois parties dans
cette épreuve pour la première à
l'ancêtre de jeu des écarts faire
[Musique]
les carter
se tenir dans l'arène il va laisser la
bâche foncé sur lui quand elle arrive
sur lui il devra piloter pour éviter et
les cornes de l'animal mais les gars
doivent être le plus petit possible
celui qui laisse la corne le frôler du
pup et obtient la meilleure note
nous avons deux écarts axe 2 pour
bayonne et dans un instant pour que vous
compreniez mesdames et messieurs il va y
avoir un écart décès pour que vous
jugiez de la difficulté de l'entreprise
et bien messieurs pour les garder c'est
quand vous voudrez il ne compte pas
voici un bel écart
mesdames et messieurs je vous demande je
vous demande de me permettre de demander
une seconde monsieur le président quelle
est la note que vous auriez accordé
trois points trois points le maximum
étant de st alors nous allons donner
deux écarts pour dax et deux écarts pour
bayonne
additionné le total des points et pour
cette épreuve
l'équipe de la ville qui aura marqué le
plus de points dans les deux écarts
donnera aux marqueurs chanteur de guy
lux un point de match pour sa bible
messieurs pour le premier et carter de
bayonne quand vous voudrez
[Musique]
monsieur le président vous donneriez 4,4
quoi
[Applaudissements]
pour les carters de nos cinq ans
voudrait des capteurs de nox maintenant
julie
m
[Musique]
bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
quatre points quatre points après le
premier quart les deux villes sont à
égalité le deuxième et carter de bayonne
quand il le fera mieux
évidemment pas
le lavage des avancées de prospectus de
l'eurovision attention
monsieur le président
moins de deux mois et demi il y a six
points et demie de jeu
après le deuxième écart pour bayonne le
deuxième et carter de dax en action
[Musique]
quand voudrais m'excuser
bref
dans le point si j'ai bien côté 1 le
jury décide 7 points pour dax 6 ennemis
pour bayonne
la victoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici la vache qui a regagné le taux rim
vous avez une seconde pour marquer les
points et les chanter guy lux si vous le
désirez bien
[Musique]
je
est-ce qu'on marque le point haut point
central non nous continue alors ici à
dax par les sauter il y a le saut
périlleux et il y a le show de bérets
nous allons faire une démonstration pour
rien de manière que les téléspectateurs
comprennent
monsieur le président vous voulez vous
s'il vous plaît expliqué le jeu le taux
horaire au lieu d'écarter la vache
levitte en l'affranchissant c'est-à-dire
un exécutant un saut au dessus d'elle
alors un coup à blanc messieurs s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
à
oui suez le pois blancs tendre et pour
nous le montrer alors ça c'est le père
yeux et puis elles sont en berne c'est
en ce que nous appelons un saut à la
cour ce ne sont périlleux tout à l'heure
à blanc mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs nous allons au printemps le
temps nous pressent faire le jeu en
commençant enfin bayonne de monsieur le
président désirez-vous commencer par le
saut périlleux le sou de béré le saut
vers et le sommer et pour le
représentant de bayonne
allons-y bessieux le zoo béret par
bayonne
quand vous voudrez messieurs non
[Musique]
bien
trois points trois points
[Musique]
n'a pas le sauveur de dax s'il vous
plaît dans le même exercice
quand vous voudrez et messieurs dès que
vous êtes prêt au centre allons-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais demi droit et demie légèrement
table
et le devenant le saut périlleux saut
périlleux par le représentant de bayonne
s'il vous plaît
je vais te le saut périlleux pour le
représentant de bayonne c'est bien cela
quand vous voudrez messieurs
[Applaudissements]
quatre points
quatre points pour bayonne bayonne a
donc cette pointe et maintenant ces
dates
3 et 4,7 points pour bayonne dax
maintenant pour le saut périlleux
exercice qui va terminer les sauts quand
vous verrez messieurs
le point 5 points mesdames et messieurs
entre un point pourtant les affaires de
dax vont bien nous allons maintenant
voir le dernier exercice
c'est à dire les raseteurs à la cocarde
2 pour dax dans l'arène et deux pour
bayonne
il s'agit d'arracher d'entre les cornes
de l'animal une deux ou trois cocarde
qui sont accrochés à vous messieurs fait
sortir l'animal du toril quand vous le
voudrez
le président l'annoncera voulez-vous me
dire quelle est la difficulté du jeu
il s'agit d'approcher suffisamment nos
navettes pour pouvoir arracher la coca
qui se trouve entre les cornes
cet exercice ne doit pas être fait en
étant protégé derrière l'atalante ère où
les refuges mais au centre où au moins
au large dans la piste mais chez quand
vous voudrez
ceux de daxon le béret je vous le
rappelle
[Applaudissements]
allez
la durée maximum du jeu est de 3 minutes
il reste donc encore deux minutes chrono
maximum
m
[Applaudissements]
in haineux pour l'instant les uns dakwar
h et une cocarde dac semaine dans cette
troisième manche
la beta plus que d'autres gardent et
nous n'avons plus que deux minutes de
jouées environ
[Musique]
je m'appelle mesdames et messieurs de
jeudi n'est qu'un jeu
[Applaudissements]
l'émission est un jeu et nous désirons
instamment lui conserver ce caractère de
la bonne franquette qu'il a
[Musique]
10 luxe vous m'entendez à bayonne je
suppose que voulez-vous me dire combien
de temps il me reste pour ce jeu car
nous n'avons pas de chronomètre ici sous
la main
[Applaudissements]
dax encore pour tremblant devant
il reste encore une cocarde mais les
deux sont à dax
[Applaudissements]
eh bien nous terminons ce jeu car d'une
part nous sommes très pressés par
l'horaire étant donné que dax a enlevé
de cocardes au pisa les dax battre et
bayonne par de cocarde à une cette
troisième manche et donc pour dax qui
marque un nouveau point un cookie luxe
eh bien eh bien eh bien bravo bravo à
dax qui marquant trois points trois
points dans cette cinquième épreuve mène
donc chanteur dit le cij pour dash
quatre fours york
[Applaudissements]
eh bien ali a mis de date
annie de bayonne et à lui de notre jeu
intervilles ce que je vais vous dire et
maintenant extrêmement important nous
avons une révision nous sommes obligés
de rendre l'antenne la sixième et ultime
épreuve va se dérouler devant les
quelque dix mille spectateurs de bayonne
ici et les 10000 spectateurs
le dax et vous en aurez les résultats à
la fin de notre série d'émissions au
cours du journal télévisé qui clôturera
notre soirée quant aux images
nous ne voulons pas vous en priver vous
les aurez au début de notre émission
évidemment ce match dax bayonne a tenu
ce qu'il promettait il est
extraordinaire il va avoir lieu au
finish
vous entendez l'ambiance est bien
maintenant nous allons vous rendre
l'antenne sur des images de dax du
taureau des frigos et nous vous
donnerons les résultats tout à l'heure
et les images jeudi prochain à 1000
intervilles excusez-nous c'est ainsi ce
fait ne se reporter au revoir
[Musique]